you
hello and welcome Karolinska Institutet
well we've just discovered who's been
awarded the 2010 Nobel Prize in
Physiology or medicine with me to
discuss this prize is Professor Krista
hug and then written a bell Prize
Committee there's a hug thank you very
much for talking to us
could we begin by you telling us who has
received the 2010 Nobel Prize in
Physiology or medicine it was Robert
Edwards and what did he receive the
prize for he received the prize for the
development of in-vitro fertilization
and in vitro fertilization is is
something that's touched lives of many
people but for anyone who's not aware of
what by vfo in-vitro fertilization is
could you explain it in simple terms
please in-vitro fertilization is a
method through which egg can be
fertilized outside the body and then
returned to the woman and then in the
woman giving rise to a baby in a natural
way and what was Robert Edwards
achievements in IVF therapy well he had
he started to work on this in the late
1950s and initially he was studying
female and male germ cells in animals
trying to understand the reproduction
process there but already during the
light late 950 s realized that much what
he knew could perhaps be used to treat
infertility human so starting perhaps in
the end of 95 90 50s he had a vision
that he could use his knowledge and
other's knowledge to transform this into
a method to treat infertility and the
first thing he actually did was to find
out how human Oh sites could be measured
in vitro and he during a ten year period
he showed step-by-step that it could be
maturity that is you took out through a
surgical procedure you took out a mature
oocyte from the women you let them
mature in vitro and in the end you could
give them sperm and he could show and it
was the first to show that you could
actually need to fertilize those sites
that been in matured in vitro
outside the body
so at that time point was a major
success to happen in 1969 it was in
media all over the world it was a
fantastic success in that sense however
he also came to the realization that the
in-vitro Machado site was a bit fragile
so he decided to shift focus and
initiate in collaboration with a very
skilled obstetrician and gynecologist
dr. Patrick Steptoe that unfortunately
died in 1988 and together with him he he
were able to retrieve maturer sites
instead of immature sites and having
access to these mature sites he could
then start over again by indeed by
fertilizing those in a cell culture dish
and then in this particular case he
could see that he formed early embryos
and that was coming close to the end of
his vision because now not a few years
later his method and resulted in the
birth of the first IVF child Grace Brown
and when was that that was in 1978 and
so that was a great breakthrough so
where are we now with life via therapy
how prevalent is it and how successful
is it nowadays depending on the country
you look at it varies from country to
country how much the IVF is used but if
you look in in the Western countries or
in developed countries between one to
five percent of the children born or
through IVF and so IVF is more of a
clinical procedure and traditionally or
more often than not the medicine prize
goes to more basic research where does
IVF therapy fits within all the other
prizes that have been awarded the
medicine price it's clearly a medicine
price and it's clearly a clinical
application and if you look in the
history I would say that this is the one
one of the first prizes awarded in the
area of reproduction so it's it it's a
unique prize within within all the
prizes since 1901 that's receive them in
surprise sounds looking into the
particular areas it is unique yes I
would say so
and of course according to the
stipulations of the prize you could have
given the prize to two or possibly three
people
what was the case for a reward in the
prize to Robert Edwards only the reason
was that he he was the one that saw the
possibility he started his many many
years ago and he had many collaborators
throughout this years but each of them
helped him with a specific task and
through in D&D and it was really Edward
that came out as seeing the vision and
making it happen and as you said earlier
the key work was done in the 1960's and
1970's and as you said the first
so-called test tube baby was born in
1978 which must maker over 30 years of
age so what was required to vote for
this prize to be the most compelling
choice this year decades later in 2010
well the reason why it was awarded this
year is that it is a very particular
case when when there is a medical award
an achievement like this you of course
have to look into the effect of the
children during the last years have been
several long term follow-up studies of
the health of these children which have
shown them to be healthy furthermore a
number of those IVF children have had
kids of their own and they are healthy
and if they happen without IVF so it all
these things coming together in the end
it was felt that this is a prize that
came given without regrets and one other
issue about IVF therapy from from the
very beginning was that there was a lot
of ethical debate about the use of human
embryos was the ethical issue something
that the committee had to consider when
awarding this prize it is true that it
was a large ethical discussion at during
the 1970s ninety nine 1980s but those
issues has been resolved when it comes
to IVF itself the base of technology of
IVF that is no longer I think debated in
any country as a technique used then of
course there are follow-up techniques
based on either
those could be more or less discussed in
different societies in different
countries but this year's prize is
awarded only for the core technology
I've ever searched and one of those
follow-up technologies that you briefly
mentioned there is a course human
embryonic stem cell research which
itself is an area of considerable
controversy now in giving this prize to
IVF therapy is the medicine committee
making a message about the use of human
embryos and research not at all actually
we are only focusing on the actually the
the IVF procedure and in IVF the embryo
which is dividing a few times and then
returned to the mother we are not
considering in any other aspect of the
embryo in this prize my final question
is did you get a chance to speak to the
laureate and not myself
no but the secretary called this morning
to them and he discussed it the fact
that Robert had been awarded prize with
his wife Ruth Fowler who said she was
very very happy and she she was sure
that Robert Ellis would be equally happy
thank you very much professor hug for
more information about this year's prize
please visit Nobel Prize org where you
can not only find official information
but you can also see an exclusive
interview with the laureates and also
send your own congratulatory message you
can also follow Nobel Prize org on
Facebook and Twitter to receive regular
news updates and to join in the
conversation and for the first time this
year we're giving you the opportunity to
submit your video question to this
year's laureates on youtube visit
www.youtube.com / 11:45 a.m. Central
European Time but for now it's goodbye
from all of us at Nobel Prize org